[Music]
as Tim was talking I was thinking about
the many conversations that we had with
Henry about some of the great human
puzzles to these problems why is it that
when Americans are polled about many of
the issues that Tim was addressing they
are supportive of the kind of strategies
and approaches that Tim outlined and yet
we cannot get the public policy
alignment in place it's a huge problem
and it's one that we need to continue to
work on it it's one that always tried
always mystified Henry because he kept
hoping that our elected officials would
be rational
I put this in one of the big issues he
worried about and indeed perhaps
understanding the science behind some of
these big issues may be easier than
understanding the human behavior that
guides some of the people who are
responding to that science today we're
going to be looking at three big issues
that Henry focused on in greater depth
biodiversity for which we need a new
name climate change and arms control we
begin with the as yet-to-be-named
biodiversity problem Ed Wilson is known
to all of us in addition to being a film
star he is the world's foremost
authority on biodiversity I know him as
one of my daughter's teachers at Harvard
and is the person who comes first to
mind on deep in the rainforest I see a
parade of leaf cutter ants crossing the
path in front of me you really want
everybody who goes into the rainforest
and sees an ant to think of you and what
we do you know his books on human nature
in the ass both of which won Pulitzer
Prizes and Concilium the listed medals
would take up the time for a speech so
with no further ado I introduce Ed
Wilson
Thank You Adele and thank you also for
the privilege of allowing me to join in
this tribute to Henry I I had the
privilege of knowing Henry Kendall
only for a relatively short time some of
you have known for virtually a lifetime
after he asked me to help him add
natural ecosystems and biodiversity to
the environmental crusade he was
spearheading under the aegis of the UCS
he was indeed oh I was there I had
trouble hearing you as well so how is it
down which probably saved me from
wincing a few times today is this coming
on okay now is it all right is it better
it needs to be up I'm I should speak
more loudly than right okay I'm not sure
whether the trouble is in the room or if
it's in the the sound system I hope
maybe we can get a increase in the
volume of the sound system is that
better is that coming okay all right
again again it says which room is filled
but MIT I should say yeah MIT know-how
and Harvard Technology
[Laughter]
now I had this I repeat myself somewhat
I had the privilege of knowing Henry
only for a short time when I joined his
crusade under the aegis of the UCS he
was indeed a brave and honorable
farsighted thoroughly admirable man and
I regret that I did not get to know him
for years more he would be greatly
missed he knew and we now fully
understand I'm so splendidly expressed
by Tim Wirth the scientist with them
everyone else are entering what can be
called a fairly the century of the
environment which in a nutshell is that
period in which humanity has got to get
settled down before we wreck the planet
now I in the first slide good today as
clearly and concisely as I can as Henry
would have liked it let me present a
picture of the status of biodiversity
most relevant to Total Environment as we
are addressing this morning I'll start
by putting a twist on it by placing
biomass and biodiversity in some
perspective and here we have
representing the relative biomasses
ants representing the invertebrates the
little things that run the earth as I
like to say with the vertebrates as
important as they are the ant biomass
alone in the Amazon rainforest and this
is true of most terrestrial environments
around the world the ant biomass the
total weight of ants alone there's just
one invertebrate group is approximately
four times that of all of the
vertebrates together the mammals and the
birds and the reptiles and the
amphibians moreover we should keep in
mind as we
enjoy and understand better the
charismatic species on the minds of all
that there is beneath them in the energy
pyramids and biomass distributions a
great mass of of species that form the
bulk of the ecosystems and these species
are indicated here in total global
biodiversity this is both terrestrial
and aquatic and marine and here you see
that the insects and the flowering
plants dominate terrestrial and aquatic
biodiversity of the world but primarily
because by almost actually 90% plus
biodiversity of terrestrial systems
which is so overwhelmingly rich in
biodiversity that the global picture is
divided thus and of the species that are
thus represented we can see perhaps more
graphically in this cartoon the species
Kate the number of species found in each
of the major groups represented by
proportionally the size of a typical
organism thus the insects with more than
half of the known species of organisms
on earth lose like a Goodyear blimp
above the tiny mammalian representative
the elephants they're there to represent
the 4,000 species of mammals and the
mammals are sort of hidden underneath
this these large mushrooms that
represent the 60,000 or so
fungal species now the important point I
want to make out of this
aside from suggesting that we always
keep in mind what the full extent of
life on Earth and particularly the
diversity is is how little we know about
the numbers of species and the full
pattern of diversity on earth to this
point we now have know and have named
some 1 and 3/4 million species of plants
animals and microorganisms but the
actual figure could be anywhere from a
quite conservative 5 million according
to some estimates to as high as a
hundred million and the fact is that we
do not know the number of species on
earth to the nearest order of magnitude
we know more about the surface of Mars
than we do about the living surface of
this planet so part of the exploration
that has to be done in biology in the
next century is to complete the great
when they an enterprise and discover and
map all of the biodiversity of the earth
even as it is rapidly disappearing and
this takes me then to the tropical
rainforests where some half or more of
all of the species of organisms are
thought to live by most specialists the
tropical rainforests in black here
covers some six percent of the land
surface of the earth that's down about
50 percent due to human activity the
rainforests the great treasure house of
the of the world is also the least
explored and part of the reason is
illustrated by this photograph of a
graduate student at Harvard in Borneo
namely climb climbing up to the canopy
namely that so much of the biodiversity
is concentrated in the canopy and yet
that is one of the most difficult
environments to get to the trees tower
often up to a hundred feet or more the
top canopy trees of the bowl or trunks
of the trees or are relatively smooth
and straight and do not put out there
are nearly horizontal limbs until near
the top the bark is often spiny if not
smooth difficult to climb and up at the
top and the branches as you can see up
in the upper left-hand corner or masses
of epiphytes in the gardens forming
gardens there orchids and gaz nereids
and bromeliads and other species as many
as fifty or even a hundred species may
be found in the canopy of a single tree
and these are dense full of spines hard
to climb through and swarming with
stinging ants and bees and wasps and
Tarzan would not have lasted 15 minutes
now great many ingenious methods are
being developed to get up there one of
them is and of course they include and
this was certainly must have warm the
spot in Henry's heart included rope
climbing standard rope climbing rock
climbing techniques to get in there up
there but also as illustrated here the
use of Bill building cranes as pioneered
by the Smithsonian Tropical Research
Organisation and it simply consists of
taking a crane up to the edge of
rainforest patches in Panama or down a
path a cut road into the rain into the
rainforest and then letting
investigators be out move out on the end
there and be lowered up and down in the
rain forest canopy or a and in addition
rotated around so this way you can get
an enormous volume covered and here is
the actual device in place and here is
the gondola here is the gondola with a
couple of botanist and they are looking
seeing and working at a spot which was
not previously accessible namely the the
outer foliage of the canopy to light to
support the human and not accessible in
any other way from the land and from the
from the ground so for the first time
they can get and look right at where the
growth is maximally occurring and where
a large amount of the biomass and
biodiversity occurs that is at least
explored they also have to be in cages
up there with a door that can be slammed
fast because of the Africanized or
killer Beach which have spread now
throughout the new world tropics and one
does not want to be dangling at the end
of a crane arm in the middle of the
canopy and when you bump into a nest of
those now the there we go
now the diversity of the rainforest is
legendary in this single from this
canopy of a single tree illustrated here
I identified some 46 species of ants
living there in 23 general and that is
about the same number of species of ants
found in all of Europe so this gives you
living in one tree so this gives you an
idea of just how rich the tropical
forests are if I may maintain emphasis
on them a bit longer the in 1955 as a
young biologist at Harvard I set the
world record for the largest number of
ants found in a single kilometer square
kilometer I was in New Guinea and 172 I
know that was a world record because it
was the first time that was done
subsequently subsequently a Brazilian
entomologist put that right up over 200
in the Brazilian environment and then a
British entomologist shoved it on up to
250 or so working in West Africa and
then a few years ago I I asked one of my
graduate students and our curatorial
assistant managing the ant collection to
go down to
the tropical and these two Equatorial
Peru where I knew others knew where
possibly the richest most biodiverse
area in the world
and I said go down and break the record
and don't come back no I didn't I just
kidding I said this was part of a very
important survey that we I'm gonna done
and and I said well you probably could
break the record which they did and it
still stands at 365 ants in about 20
acres so I could go on and on by with
the stories of this kind but must move
on and emphasize that in spite of the
stress proper stress on the top of a
forest which is is being destroyed in an
accelerating rate we must not forget the
other terrestrial environments which
have richness --is distinctive to
themselves and are also in most parts of
the world under severe stress right here
at home the temperate forest is
surprisingly unexplored at the mezzo and
micro levels when we are in a forest and
look down on the forest floor we think
we see is a two dimensional world and
and and that is in a in a sense correct
because we are from among the largest
organisms on Earth and we were rather
like Godzilla you know walking through
New York City everything sort of looks
flat down there but when you magnify the
whole thing and
well
we are advancing regardless of a button
not push yeah it's not UI
I'm glad to see and in in spite of the
in spite of the computer revolution in
the the prospects of petaflop
in spite of petaflop computers in our
near future the human element is still
needed thank you sir
anyway now we are side view of this
magnified many times so that you see
over a distance of only a few
centimetres and that once you see this
is a three-dimensional world for the
majority of the species of organisms
namely as you go from the top with dry
leaves recently fallen large spaces a
certain chemical regime and high
temperatures in an aggregate way of
light millimeter by millimeter down
through the leaf litter and into the
humans in in stages you are descending
into different worlds of physical
chemical and biological world as though
you were descending the ocean
ten meters at a time and it is the this
enormous diversity in the natural ground
of a terrestrial ecosystem that provides
a huge array of niches for every level
in the trophic web and this is what
holds this this ensemble with its
material cycles and balances of
populations and so on that holds the
natural environment into the steady
state that we so desire to see it kept
and the diversity here of small
organisms here we have them for a single
square foot roughly of Panamanian
rainforest ground is quite staggering
into the tens of thousands of
individuals and many hundreds of species
in in just a square foot and looking at
the the environment scaled down in this
way we see that what is apparent as a as
just a small fragment of the passing
environment from the point of view of a
flying bird or ourselves walking by is
the equivalent of an island for some of
the smaller organisms for most of the
smaller organisms and here is an example
of how a rotting stump is at different
stages in a temperate forest divided up
among one particular group of organisms
of fly larvae out of hundreds and so you
can you can see that the micro ecology
of any chosen group of smaller sized
physical size is itself a subject for a
proper life time study many of these
species would be undescribed even here
in New England
one can spend a lifetime in a magic
magellanic voyage around one tree stump
once you scale down a size and an area
of space in your studies the what is
biodiversity I suggest that if we have
to have a
new name as Tim worth thinks might be
useful for public education we might try
creation but on the other hand I think
that the unfamiliarity of the word
biodiversity comes less from its
technological ambience than from the
fact that to the importance of
biodiversity and the magnitude of the
insult of letting species of
environmental insult of species growing
a strength is a lot it's much harder for
the average person to understand than is
the say the polluting of a river or the
rising of global temperature so it's a
matter more of Education and this is an
area where scientists in addition to
research and counselling and activism
should be more fully engaged diverse a
biodiversity then is all of life and it
is made that is made less than banal by
recognizing biologists study it in
horizontal sections going from
ecosystems as the main main level in
which diversity occurs to the species
that compose it as seen in this
Australian example down to smaller
organisms and then beyond that the the
genic or genomic diversity within
individual species yes and we should
bear in mind that at that last level the
diversity becomes immense a
back-of-the-envelope estimate of a
diversity that takes into account the
species all the species and all of the
genes
and the possible genic variation that
may occur takes us to 10 to the 17 given
order of magnitude of how much
biodiversity there is in the earth at
the present time in the case of DNA many
of you will recognize this as a panel
showing the actual DNA molecules little
micro spaghetti all through there for
one part out of 4,500 of the total human
genome so if you just extended that on
4,500 times each with a different part
of the genome you would get the what's
in a single cell another way of putting
it is to recognize that if we put all of
the four DNA strands of a diploid
nucleus from the human body in don't in
and real space it would stretch for
roughly one meter but it would only be
two nanometers across so you wouldn't
see it even though you would literally
could hold that molecule and it would be
that long however if we could magically
increase it in thickness until it was as
thick as a piece of wrapping string then
we would get this kind of a of a ramping
up namely that our DNA molecule a
molecule now as thick as a piece of
wrapping string would extend
approximately one thousand eight hundred
and twenty miles or the distance between
New York and Dallas and as you walked
along it through that distance you would
be reading off nucleotides about 100
nucleotides an inch and that is bearing
in mind because the uniqueness of a
species in that code is what we lose
when we lose a species not to mention
what could be an important part of the
ecosystem are not even that
certainly on average a million years or
more of genetic evolutionary history oh
I did want to mention as a personal note
about this this route into biology
because it's worth noting particularly
this close to MIT that there is more
than one way to go into science and the
nice thing about entering science as a
naturalist which was my ontogeny is that
it is a lifelong occupation that it can
it fascinates and can grip youngsters as
as early as they're well as early as 9
or 10 to acquire a an affiliation with
the natural world comes very easily for
children as I have always said every kid
has this bug period and the only thing
different about me as I never grew out
of mine and so here I am as a 13 year
old in Mobile Alabama collecting insects
and Here I am 50 years later
nothing changed basically except that I
got a great job at Harvard doing this
and also I guess my vocabulary group any
right the other thing that happened
along along the way is what happened to
so many of us now in the environment
movement and to so many of those
dedicated to the basic and applied
studies of biodiversity namely the
recognition that the natural world is
disappearing at an accelerating rate the
rainforests are disappearing at the rate
of about one to two percent a year I
thought you just as an example and
certainly the the most important single
example if if the rainforest cover an
area of forty eight they do cover an
area of approximately equal to the 48
contiguous United States and they are
disappearing being clear cut down to
below ten percent of cover at the rate
of the area of Florida each year
and of those remaining as in the
Brazilian Amazon now that we are getting
more finally if I finally resolved
photographs and on-the-ground analyses
furthermore those that survived are
being cut in two by trails that aren't
so easily observed from the air and
other changes are occurring that are
degrading and fragmenting the rainforest
and here is the decline for example of
one of the most beautiful and richest of
all over 150 years or so almost yes over
150 years this is a state of South Paulo
and the black is the the Magnificent
Atlantic forest with a very distinctive
fauna and flora down through way below
10% of what it was yes and we can see as
you saw briefly in the film shown at the
outset that the humanity is changing the
whole surface quite visibly this is the
collage or a composite I should say of
photographs taken by the US Air Force
satellite weather monitoring survey
showing how the world really looks at
night if there were no clouds obscuring
your view and you can see that the
eastern seaboard the United States is
expected in Europe and an incandescent
Japan are all lit lit up but also that
there are great many small pinpoints of
light through less inhabited areas in
the Brazilian Amazon and then the and
then the congo basin and in the sub
Saharan desert these are fires being
burning up the the fallen cut timber
rubbish left from it and firing the
grasslands of the of the drier areas
NASA estimates that five percent of the
Earth's land surface is burned each year
right and as the area of habitats
decline we know that there is a quite
steady and predictable decline in the
fauna and flora the numbers of species
and this relation is illustrated here
not by the physical decline of habitats
but the same thing applies in the West
Indies where the area is the area uses
that of the standing Antillean Islands
from Cuba down to small islands like
redonda we see that the number of
species that stabili exists there drops
50% for every 10 fold reduction area you
lose 90% you lose eventually half of the
species this is well illustrated and
this is true of habitats Islands as well
as regular oceanic island and this is
well illustrated by our National Park
System parks of the western United
States and South Western Canada are in
fact islands in a growing sea of human
habitation habitation and other
disturbed environments and just as
predicted by our worldwide observations
of the pattern of biodiversity and by
the theory of turnover of species
developed by biologists the phonons are
spontaneously dropping now let's see I
think I must there we are
yes this the this is the number of
mammal species dropping as it has
dropped and parks overall in the last
hundred years not all a mammal species
will disappear but there'll be this
continuous autonomous endogenous loss of
species no matter how carefully the
parks are protected now this is a
sobering aspect of the loss of diversity
through habitat destruction and
yes this is the nature conservancy's
latest report on the United States of a
hundred and twenty thousand species we
know roughly plants and animals about
about one percent of certified extinct
and thirty percent are in varying
degrees of endangerment
it is far worse than that in most of the
developing countries but I thought I
would bring it a little closer to home
to show you that right here we are
suffering the same amount of stress the
red states which include Hawaii and
California and unfortunately my native
state of Alabama are among those in
which the species extinction and shift
to vulnerability is maximum now I will
conclude this by showing you the faces
of extinct and endangered species
because it is my conviction that only by
coming to know these species as
individuals as entities million-year-old
entities that we have inherited that are
part of our lives in our environment
only by coming to know them as
individuals can we expect the public to
care about whether they will be
preserved otherwise they just become
statistics and people are might be very
willing to live with twenty or thirty or
forty percent fewer species on earth if
they know nothing at all else about what
is this is doing to us and know nothing
at all about what these species are so
here are the portraits of several the
cerulean paradise flycatcher of
indonesian newly extinct the golden toad
of costa rica on its way only discovered
a few decades ago on its way to becoming
the
national symbol of Costa Rica's Natural
History extinct within the last several
years the hawaiian honeycreepers this
magnificent explosion of species that
occurred over a couple of million years
in Hawaiian archipelago now extinct to
the level of 75% with most of the other
species hanging on by a thread several
critically endangered the Hawaiian
abandoned snails tree snail half extinct
the others endangered the tennessee
coneflower endangered McFarland's four
o'clock endangered the silver sort of
hawaii endangered but fortunately under
strict protection the world's most
endangered species a cook's kokyo a
magnificent flowering shrub that once
covered a whole hawaiian island now
existing only as ten implants into
stocks of other species
they can't they don't even have enough
genetic capacity to germinate as they
exist today so they're just hanging on
in that respect so I will conclude by
saying looking at this slide which shows
the five great extinction spasms of the
past four hundred and fifty million
years that have been worked out by
paleontologists caused and at least in
the last case the one that closed the
Mesozoic 65 million years ago by the
massive bolide strike at the Yucatan
Peninsula and under
research and discussion as to what what
the main cause is is under research and
discussion for the others but it's
happened very roughly about every 100
million years in the time of Earth's
history that a large organisms have
flourished and have invaded the land and
now we are in the midst of the sixth
great extinction we are in the early
stages of it and the question is are we
going to let it happen in full sight as
part of the degradation of our ecosystem
of the ecosystem services of all that
biodiversity can provide us in the way
of new product of new ideas of new
scientific knowledge of in the view of
of the ethical concerns that the that
preserving the rest of life on Earth of
the creation should be a primary ethical
precept in in view of all this will we
let it go on will we let it become the
six the sixth great extinction in the
history of life the natural world is
indeed endangered but it is not too
there too late to make a big difference
we're going to lose a lot of
biodiversity as you saw happening at
least locally in the case of the the
National Park but with exact knowledge
and desire we can help to slow and
eventually stop the hemorrhaging right
now the world population is just past
officially six billion and it will go
somewhere to where somewhere between
eight and ten billion by mid-century and
hopefully peak with a little bit of luck
and we humanity have to hope we have to
believe that our species is going to
pass through this bottleneck of
overpopulation and the thrusting upward
of the developing countries to attain a
decent standard
living in such a way that we will come
out overall as a species better off than
we started but we hold we we have to
have I think as a moral and parody that
in so passing through it we will not
destroy any more of the natural
environment and the species diversity
than then then is necessary then not
allow any more that we can possibly
prevent we should try to carry as much
of life through the bottleneck as we can
we must do what we can to save the
creation and not to push the rest of
life off the face of the earth we should
remember that along with culture itself
that inheritance will be the most
precious gift that we can give the
future generations thank you
thank you very much Evan I did want to
assure you that when I'm in the
rainforest and looking at leaf cutter
ants I think of you but not when those
little red ones come and sting me um Ted
sizer who is my mentor in educational
matters as much as Henry was on many
other matters always said that when he
was teaching what he wanted always to be
able to do was to say to people every 45
minutes stand up and stretch so this is
not a coffee break but if you want to
stand up for 30 seconds and stretch and
whatever we're gonna come back and then
move on to another talk
okay folks that's it
this searchlight is only meant for the
speaker here that's all watching showing
slides also I don't know where is he
okay so they should turn that off okay
well it should have just had a standing
one here I don't know where
okay
we're reconvening a chemist by training
Bob Watson has devoted most of his
professional life to shaping and
strengthening the international
institutions that have an environmental
impact and that indeed determined the
international agenda in dealing with
these issues
he is currently director for the
environment and head of the
environmental sector board at the World
Bank he also helped to shape and
establish the global environmental
facility which is a central part of the
World Bank's grant making environmental
work one of the areas of that Bob is
focused on is climate change and I hope
all of you had a chance to see The Wall
Street Journal article this past Tuesday
which was buried in their second section
but it was an extraordinary cover
section devoted to climate change it it
isn't all of your daily reading try to
find someone who can give you a copy of
it it's even better than taking it off
the website because of the graphics that
they used it's quite wonderful to have
indeed this issue receive the kind of
coverage that the journal gave it just
this week indeed that's something that I
think would have pleased Henry a great
deal but getting governments to agree
and to work together around the issue of
climate change is no small matter
getting the scientists to agree on the
science part of it is in a central piece
of getting the government's agreement
and laying the basis for international
action as chair of the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change bob has been
working to make this happen and will
continue to do so he has received as
many many awards and continues to be
very active in a full range of
international
stations but today we're asking him to
address the issue of climate change
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
okay is it now yes I've learnt I can
speak and Lord it's even this large
often without a mic let me give you
however I've been asked to talk about
climate change but let me first say and
I think this is how Henry would have
started this
Henry cared about people the environment
and science and technology the challenge
we've got in reality is how to alleviate
the poverty that's pervasive in this
world as Tim Wirth's said a quarter of
the world's population lives on one
dollar a day that's actually the cost of
my hotel room last night here half the
world's population lives on $2 a day
that would be two nights at this hotel
nearly a billion people are currently
malnourished 1.3 billion people live
without clean water 2 billion people
without sanitation 2 billion people live
without electricity between one and a
half and two billion people live with
either indoor air pollution or outdoor
air pollution five million children die
of waterborne diseases or air pollution
each year all of it avoidable the
problem is as we try and meet one of the
basic human needs of food something
Henry felt passionately about with the
turban our environment as we use
excessive nitrogen fertilizers
we're starting to contribute to climate
change and as the climate changes it
makes it harder to meet food supply
especially in the tropics as we
extensive I in other words we cut down
more forests more land for agriculture
with destroying our forests we fragment
ate the habitat we lose biodiversity the
ecosystem species and genetic level
maybe we lose it at the genetic level it
once again threatened its food supply
and if we use irrigation unwisely in
many cases a lethal salination of the
soils land degradation and once again we
threaten food supply so with the current
practices that we try and meet the basic
demand for food we're destroying our
environment and as we destroy our
environment it makes it much harder to
meet that basic human need in the first
place we currently have six major global
environmental issues all connected to
local and regional environmental issues
climate change loss of biological
diversity land degradation stratospheric
ozone depletion for these first four we
have global conventions and the world is
to some degree trying to get to grips
with these we also have principles
enunciated in Rio on forestry and fresh
and marine waters one of the problems is
even though both the scientific
community and the political community
have realized these are key issues and
I'd put a 7th persistent organic
pollutants which is almost also a global
issue we treat them in isolation and in
reality they're highly powerful as we
change prior we change the structure and
functioning of ecological systems and we
change the ecological systems at the
ecosystem species and genetic level and
as we change biodiversity we change the
biogeochemical cycling of the earth the
exchange of chemicals and energy between
the atmosphere the ocean and the land as
we change climate we change the
temperature structure the atmosphere
that affects the rate of stratospheric
ozone depletion due to chlorine and
bromine containing compounds and there's
the chlorine and bromine to containing
compounds destroy ozone it
the temperature structure that again
feeds back on climate strong links also
between climate desert vacation water
and forestry the challenge we have is to
understand these scientific linkages and
the policy linkages to identify the
win-win solutions and to recognize the
trade-offs unfortunate at the moment we
tend to look at these in splendid
isolation the key question is what are
the underlying causes they're basically
the same independent of which issue look
at these are not in an order of priority
its population growth as Tim Wirth has
already talked about to increase demand
for biological resources and energy as a
function of economic growth and
population growth and as Tim also said
it's primarily consumption patterns in
the north but exacerbated and will be
exacerbated by population growth
primarily in developing countries the
inappropriate use of technologies even
after we understood that chlorine and
bromine containing compounds were
destroying ozone we still carried on
using them for a decade or more even now
as we understand that the burning of
fossil fuels is leading to local air
pollution regional acid deposition and
global warming we continue to use fossil
fuels we have to recognize that the
markets do not work we don't they do not
recognize the value of natural resources
there are no markets for pollination
services for water purification for
cleaning the air and even if we could
make the markets work the challenge will
be to appropriate the global value
down to the local level to the landless
peasant we have to recognize we don't
internalize the social costs of most of
our actions the price of coal does not
include the environmental damage to
human health or ecological systems if it
did it would be much more expensive and
it would allow for energy efficiency and
renewable energies to be competitive on
the world's markets we have to recognize
her both institutional and government
failures we understand about fisheries
but fisheries are collapsing around the
world mainly because we don't enforce
those very regulations that were based
on reasonably sound science
and unfortunately most people don't look
ahead they don't care about their
children grandchildren yes a lot let
alone
the generations to come but I wasn't
asked to talk about that I was asked to
talk about climate change the issue is
very simply as we burn as we produce
energy from burning of fossil fuels coal
oil and gas as we DeForest the tropics
we put more greenhouse gases into the
Earth's atmosphere as we put more
greenhouse gases into the Earth's
atmosphere we believe we are indeed
changing the Earth's climate this figure
shows the co2 emissions over the last
140 years and they grow in continuously
as I say due to energy policies and the
land use policies and atmospheric
concentration of co2 is going up the
background concentration of co2 at the
beginning of the Industrial Revolution
was around 280 parts per million today
is 360 parts of a million a 25 percent
increase is it easy to understand the
climate system no first we have to
understand human activities we have to
understand population we have to
understand economic growth we have to
understand the availability of energy we
have to understand how research and
development may change energy
technologies we have to understand the
policy formulation process of how those
energy technologies will penetrate the
marketplace we have to understand the
natural forcing of the earth system
changes in solar radiation changes in
volcanic activity and within that we
have to understand the interplay between
the physical chemical and biological
system what would we predict though from
theory would happen with more greenhouse
gases first there should be an increase
in temperature more in winter than is
summer so there should be more
precipitation especially in winter third
very very iffy issue this one reduction
in the Asian monsoon precipitation we
expect longer-lasting droughts
especially in summer we expect nighttime
temperatures to increase more than
daytime temperatures and we'll expect
more heavy competitive rainfall we
actually
serving all of these this is temperature
for the last hundred years the red spot
show areas where the temperatures
increased the move spots which is only
five on there in total I think so it's
decreased literally the Earth's mean
surface temperature has increased this
is putting it this Green Line is indeed
the temperature increase over the last
100 years it's increased about 0.6
degrees centigrade on average the land
surface temperatures about 0.8 and the
oceans about 0.4 is it consistent with
theory the simple models clearly don't
try and simulate all the bumps and
Wiggles which are due to changes in
solar output volcanic eruption and the
natural exchange of energy between the
atmosphere and the ocean but the model
is basically consistent with a theory
that suggests in a double co2 world the
Earth's mean equilibrium temperature
will increase three degrees centigrade
doesn't sound a lot if you remember the
last life's ice age was only 5 degrees
cooler than it is today so a 3 degrees
centigrade is a very significant change
if however we toe a more sophisticated
model and look at the change of
temperature as a function of latitude
the equator here South Pole north pole
closer the Earth's means the Earth's
surface and close to the tropopause 1015
kilometers above the Earth's surface if
we had a model only had greenhouse gases
we think the earth would become warmer
it become warmer basically to date by
about one to two degrees centigrade
these are the observations over the last
25 years and as you can see the
observation suggests warming in the
southern hemisphere less warming in the
northern hemisphere calling up high so
the co2 model isn't exactly perfect it
doesn't show the inter hemisphere it's
like a symmetry if however we also allow
that when you burn coal you also put
sulfur dioxide into the Earth's
atmosphere which becomes actually the
formation of acid deposition you
effectively get a calling in some parts
of the earth and what happens is there's
an offset of the co2 warming in the
northern hemisphere due to the large
amount of salt
outside putting by burning fossil fuels
in the northern hemisphere now when you
compare this calculation to the
observation you see the entertainment
into hemispheric asymmetry and to a
first degree the actual magnitude of the
projected climate change is similar to
what we've actually observed you could
say that we haven't got the transition
between warming and cooling correct
between the models but I bought the more
sophisticated slide that shows taken
into account stratospheric ozone
depletion the transition between warming
and cooling becomes almost perfect okay
now the question is what's likely to
happen in the future
depending on what population increases
you predict depending on what you
believe will happen to energy prices
economic growth we believe atmospheric
emissions of co2 will increase we
believe atmospheric co2 could increase
from 360 parts per million today to
somewhere between 500 parts per million
and 1000 parts per million in other
words by 2100 even the optimistic
scenario would be a doubling of
pre-industrial co2 and the otherwise it
could even be tripling or quadrupling
what would that mean a one to three and
a half degrees centigrade increase in
temperature even the lower level would
be a rate of climate change faster than
anything observed in the last 10,000
years is the temperature increase
uniform the answer's no land surface is
more warm more than oceans and the polar
regions will more than mid latitudes
this is a projection for the 2050s if
you look at Africa or Latin America ones
projecting a 4 to 5 degree temperature
increase in only 5 decades the oceans
are not warming as much and a high
Arctic is warming probably equal to
Africa and Latin America so we see very
very large changes in temperature
especially in these particular areas
that's what I want to focus on in part
of my talk have we seen a change in
precipitation the answer is yes it
doesn't take rocket science to work out
if you warm the oceans you get more
evaporation hence you should get more
precipitation
question is where and when what we see
in the green spots are parts in the
world where it's become wetter and the
red is where it's become drier please
note the southern part of Europe the
northern part of Africa and the southern
part of Africa have all become drier in
the last 100 years theory suggested that
we should get more precipitation in
winter this is the United States and as
you can see in the last couple of
decades that has indeed been an increase
in precipitation in winter Theory also
suggested that there should be more
heavy precipitation events this again is
the United States the definition of a
heavy precipitation event in this
particular analysis is two inches of
rain within 24 hours and what you see is
indeed an increase in precipitation in
heavy events
there's also another slide which kind of
is complements this which is what's
happened to light precipitation events
and they've actually decreased in the
United States what this actually leads
to is in an area which has say no change
in annual precipitation one will have
both more floods and more droughts in
the same place a very perverse outcome
this is the projection for rainfall
precipitation in the 2050s the what the
prediction is for africa northern africa
southern europe through to the middle
east and southern africa projected to be
drier if we're the simulated backwards
for 50 years it would have been exactly
the same pattern if you remember the
pattern i showed earlier of
precipitation changes across the world
it's exactly this pattern when i say
exactly it broadly matches it's not a
perfect match there are inconsistencies
but the picture is fairly solid it's
this type of information that Tim Wirth
referred to when the IPCC says it is now
a discernible human influence on the
Earth's climate system the things to
note are indeed the areas where it's
projected to get drier that is to say
through Africa the Middle East and the
southern part of Africa one of the key
questions is will it be more hurricanes
or not there's been a very contentious
issue
the observational record of the last
hundred years for the United States
shows there has been no change in either
the frequency or the magnitudes of
hurricanes hitting the United States is
also suggestive from the theoretical
models that we don't know if it will
change in the future some models do
suggest an increase in the frequency and
magnitude of hurricanes others don't but
the observational record to date says no
significant change in the Hurricanes
hitting the United States one of the
real questions that we have to ask
yourself is will the flow of energy and
the circulation of the oceans change
this is a schematic of Wally Broecker
showing I won't go into details that
there's basically an ocean conveyor belt
that runs around the earth and in
particular the key area is in off of
Greenland in the North Atlantic where
there is a downwelling of water from the
Earth's surface down into the depths
it's the way the ocean circulates and it
comes back in deep water one of the
questions it is in a warmer world can we
stop the ocean circulation if so there
would be tremendous changes in the
Earth's climate in all regions of the
world why could you conceivably change
the ocean circulation belt very simply
at the moment the water off Greenland is
very cold and very very saline and it
sinks in a warmer world the warmer the
temperature would go up so it's got less
reason to sing but even worse the
Greenland ice belt or ice sheet could
also melt making it less saline so in
two reasons it'll become less saline
less cold it won't sink is there any
theoretical observation to say this is
likely to occur this is a little model
put together by the British Met Office
they actually went back a hundred years
the black line is what they ran the
ocean circulation model for about a
hundred years or 200 years and they said
what would normally be the downwelling
or the convective overturning of the
ocean it was the black line they then
said well what if in 1900 we've actually
started increasing atmospheric co2 at
two percent per year and it suggests
that after only a few years you would
have a significant change in the
overturning of the Oh
they then simulated what's actually
happening which is the business-as-usual
greenhouse gas emissions and they
actually started at the real time and
you can see it follows nicely but they
suddenly start to see in their model a
significant change in the downwelling of
water off of our Greenland Willis occur
it's not clear but many theoretical
models show this type of behavior and it
could mean there could be a nonlinear
response to the climate system with
respect with respect to our increases of
greenhouse gases there's another
interesting issue all of you've heard
about the El Nino phenomena is a
periodicity in the climate that occurs
naturally every two to seven years and
when it occurs there are major shifts in
the Earth's climate naturally throughout
the world will in a normal year an on El
Nino year you have the ocean off of the
South America this is South America the
ocean moves east to west you have some
moderate convective activity at the
equatorial belt and you see an
atmospheric circulation here the
intensity of the hydrological cycle is
by the amount of cloudiness we see here
we also see that effectively the ocean
returns this way and so you have the
nutrients or the thermatron right up
against the ocean surface very very
intense nutrients are very very
effective fisheries very efficient
fisheries off of Latin America but in an
El Nino year which occurs naturally
there is a major shift in the direction
of the ocean instead of east to west it
becomes west to east you now suppress
the thermocline
off of Latin America you suppress where
the nutrients are and basically you have
mass extinctions of fish very natural
process but you also have an incredible
intensification of the Illinois no
phenomena largely because the ocean
becomes much much warmer this shows what
happens in sea the sea surface
temperature nominally that is the
difference between an El Nino year and a
non El Nino year and this was for 1997
one of the most intense in vents that's
ever occurred in the last 150 years the
temperature of Peru became five
degrees warmer than normal and one saw a
massive warming of the complete Pacific
Ocean which led to a major changes of
the precipitation patterns around the
world the question is could global
warming affect the magnitude and
frequency of El Nino events this is a
measure of the El Nino event it doesn't
matter what it is but it's a measure the
ridges are when we have an El Nino event
the blue years are normal or La Nina
event there is indications in the last
20 or 30 years both the magnitude and
the frequency of the El Nino phenomena
has increased and many of the
theoretical models suggest that in the
future we could expect both more El
Ninos and more intense El Ninos and what
what happens in El Nino year what you
see in Latin America is you have floods
in Peru you have droughts in Northeast
Brazil you have droughts in southern
Africa floods in Tanzania and in Kenya
you have major droughts in Australia and
major droughts in Southeast Asia if we
were to intensify the frequency and
magnitude of the El Nino phenomena which
goes above than the average increase
that I showed you earlier there could be
major dislocations around the world if I
look at the temperature the
precipitation patterns rather in
Zimbabwe in Malawi over the last 20
years you see a very high spectrum a lot
of natural variability in precipitation
and this is going from an El Nino year
to an NT on the aerial Armenia but what
you also see now is the southern part of
Africa even in the wettest of years is
becoming lower than a century mean and
this is leading to more and more
exacerbation of the difficulty of
producing food in the southern parts of
Africa this shows you the linkages
between the El Nino phenomena and maize
production in Malawi Zimbabwe and Zambia
and as you can see there's an incredible
correlation between the maize production
and the El Nino phenomena we now however
have in a scientific community the
ability to project and predict climate
three to six months in advance and if
indeed rather than the farmer just
assuming it's going to be an average
year which it never is in Africa if we
can tell them whether it's going to rain
more or less whether the rains are going
to come early or late they can choose
when to plant and when that whether to
plant a dry crop or wet crop and indeed
this is just a this shows you the
ability and this was for 1997 the last
very major El Nino event this is the
model is a probabilistic model we don't
just save so to get wetter or a dryer
but we project through the probability
of becoming wetter in different parts of
Africa for example or the probability
becoming drier and if one looks between
the projection and what actually
happened in 1997 it's not a perfect fit
indeed got it right here there was an
informal rain just as projected it
became far drier here just as projected
and became far drier here we missed this
part here where the model predicted it
was going to get drier it actually was
wetter but to a fair degree we're
starting to have the ability to predict
3 to 6 months in advance what is likely
to happen to precipitation patterns in
places such as Africa Latin America and
Southeast Asia this saw these types of
advances in scientific prediction will
allow much wiser water resource
management health care because of
vector-borne diseases such as malaria in
countries in the tropics but there is an
interesting problem and that is if
indeed the El Nino phenomena because of
global warming
it really will indeed make it very very
difficult for water resource management
in Africa this quickly shows what's
happened in Brazil where they have tried
to use these El Nino forecasts in 1987
there was now action we had no ability
to project the El Nino situation they
only received 70% of the normal
precipitation 30% less than normal the
grain crop instead of an average of 650
thousand tons per year was only a
hundred thousand in other words they
only had fifth
dean percent of the normal grain crop
they lost 85% in the following years
there was indeed action taken 1992 very
similar to 1990 at 1987 and yet the
grain crop was almost normal 530
thousand tons and I was 82% they only
lost 18%
they changed the planting time 1993
there was only half the normal
precipitation yield dropped tremendously
to 250,000 but still not as bad as in
1987 and then we projected for 1994 is
going to be a very rainy year
precipitation was 120 percent normal the
grain production doubled the normal this
looks a very good news story it was the
only problem is I had no grain storage
capacity all the excess wasted and so
basically if one starts to learn how to
utilize this information one can put in
the capacity for either whether it be
dams water reservoirs but also for grain
storage and this is one area we have to
start to move forward on we have to
prevent what we have to get upstream
normally what happens is we have an
agricultural season insufficient rain a
drought agricultural productivity shrink
it sort of drops there's a drought
appeal the US Europe the other donors
all come through with money but by the
time they come through with money you're
in the middle of the heavy rains it's a
totally hopeless approach basically so
we now have to start to use the science
for wise resource management but to go
back to the long-term impacts of climate
change why do we care we care for the
very things that Henry cared about water
food health impacts we have to look at
the impact of the change of temperature
precipitation and sea-level not only the
mean but the variability on health
primarily vector borne diseases
agricultural productivity the impact on
our forests our water and our coastal
zones and there are indeed major issues
with relating to species diversity if
you remember the pictures I showed you a
little while ago I saw Africa getting
very hot
I also saw less precipitation in Africa
this is annual runoff and what you can
see in the northern part of Africa
through the southern part of Europe into
the Middle East and in southern Africa
decreased by at least a factor a two in
runoff
what will that mean it means that there
could be significant changes in water
stress today about 19 countries 20
countries around the world a water
stressed or water scarce this number
will double in the next 25 years
independent of climate change just
because of population growth an economic
growth
we would expect rather in 10 to 20
percent of the world today being water
scarce it would be significantly higher
climate change is an additional factor
or an additional stress that will
effectively exacerbate the problems of
water scarcity in northern Africa
southern Africa through the Middle East
with respect to India in the US it's so
close that some models this model
suggests that India becomes water scarce
and America actually becomes less water
scarce but another model shows the us
become more water scarce in India a
little less all the other countries
though are very robust independent of
the models the keys are trying to
understand India is predicting what will
happen to the Indian monsoon is very
very tough to do that all of these other
countries that read were read in the
previous document the u.s. also it seems
a little trick it's on the margin of a
slight decrease to a slight increase in
precipitation as I've already said today
99 a roughly 90 percent of the
population has relative sufficiency of
water independently climate change by
2050 only 60 percent of the world
climate change will exacerbate this and
it'll be less than 50 percent will be
water secure but then we get to food a
major challenge it's not surprising
those countries that now have less
precipitation less runoff if you look in
Africa and in Latin America those
countries that are in yellow or orange
is where agricultural productivity will
decrease this particular model shows a
decrease of anywhere from 10 to 30
percent in agricultural yield in Africa
and in Latin America and especially in
Africa where most of the people today
already subject to malnutrition and
malnourishment in other words there is a
major equity issue here
is primarily the developed world the US
Japan and Europe that are putting the
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere
this primarily the developing countries
that suffer the consequences of changes
in water and hence agricultural
productivity overall if I were to
integrate this picture there's little or
no major change in global production but
there's major regional changes and the
question is is Africa going to grow
wealthy enough to buy food from North
America and the other countries where
food may actually increase in
productivity I personally doubt it if
you look at vegetation types and don't
even try and look for the changes it's
very hard to see but we also have to
look to see what could happen to the
major biomes and ecological systems of
the world from this particular model
what we find is when you have a bar at
the top it suggests an increase so that
suggests a certain area increase in
deserts there will be some areas that
are currently desert today that will
change from deserts so overall an
increase in desert area overall an
increase in temperate grasslands a major
decrease in tropical grasslands roughly
the same amount of temperate tropical
forest roughly the same amount but a
major shift in location of at coniferous
a deciduous forest overall an increase
in temperate forests and roughly no
major change in coniferous forests so
some major changes in where the location
of some of these major ecological
systems will be if one has looked
carefully at this previous vegetation
map one would have seen that the east
coast of the United States has the
potential to remain forested and if you
also ask yourself the question will it
be the same foresters today the answers
now today that is the potential for
beech trees up and down the complete
east coast of the United States in a
double co2 world when the ecological
system comes to equilibrium with the
climate system which would take a long
period of time one would argue beech
trees would no longer be viable nor
would sugar maples in the United States
only in Canada so the key issue is even
when you see that an ecological system
like a forest is
rejected to stay a forest there may be
major changes in species composition
which has major changes in the
ecological goods and services they
provide
one of the most disconcerting issues is
at this moment in time the world's
terrestrial ecosystems actually our sink
overall for co2 there absorb in co2 in
that warmer world and a change from
hydrological world even after taking
into account the co2 fertilization
effect the models are predicting most of
them that instead of the terrestrial
biosphere being a sink for carbon
dioxide it will become a source
potentially a major die back in some of
the ecosystems of the world if that were
to occur my stress if if it were to
occur it would exacerbate and catalyze
even further global warming
clearly climate change is not the major
threat to the forest systems of the
world in Russia and Europe we only have
about 30 percent of the original forests
left this is completely cleared this has
been modified and this is frontier
forests in Asia there's less than 10% of
the original forest cover North America
about 1/3 maybe 40% South America about
1/2 Africa again down to temptin of
original frontier forests the way to
view climate changes it's not the major
threat to food the major threats of food
is we need more food as a growing
population and economic growth the major
threats of the forest isn't climate
change but climate change is a very
major additional stress and we have to
look at climate change in the full
socio-economic picture and in its own
right it is a very serious environmental
issue we need to get to grips with what
else do we have to worry about from
climate change as I mentioned earlier in
a warmer world we would have to worry
about human health heat stress mortality
we saw about three years ago in Chicago
when it was unusually warm both day and
night over 500 people died within a
three day period
it wasn't the high daytime temperatures
it's the very high nighttime
temperatures for those that were
socially
the poor who didn't have
air-conditioning but the big issue is
the issue of the vector borne diseases
today there's about 300 million new
cases of malaria per year roughly 2
million people died primarily in the
tropics in a double co2 world we'd
expect those numbers to go up by about
25 percent in other words an additional
50 to 80 million cases of malaria per
year an additional half a million people
dying per year because of malaria one
also has to worry about dengue fever and
the other vector borne diseases and
waterborne diseases such as cholera
we're willows most of those cases of
malaria occur even though there's a
potential for malaria to spread into the
United States and Europe the health care
system here will take care of it to a
large degree but the places where it'll
get worse is where it's already bad
primarily in Africa Latin America and
parts of Southeast Asia again please
note it's the developing countries that
once again suffer sea-level rise 1/2
meter 550 centimeter sea-level rise what
the implications major loss of wetlands
up in this part of the world and here
potentially between 10 and 50 million
people being displaced around Africa
potentially 50 to a hundred million
people being displaced in Southeast Asia
and up in the up in the China the
low-lying deltaic areas in Bangladesh
Egypt and China tens of millions of
environmental refugees small island
states like the Maldive islands where
there's 1,200 islands average height 3
feet in one or two centuries could
conceivably disappear a complete loss of
cultures this shows you the map of
Bangladesh it doesn't show very well and
I apologize this is a current coastline
with a 1 meter this is 1 meter sea-level
rise it moves in about half an inch on
here 70 million that 70 million people
if they're half the rice is grown there
Bangladesh is one of the poorest
countries in the world one of the most
complex deltaic systems it doesn't have
the option
the Netherlands have just built-in sea
dikes so whether we go from here I'm not
going to go into all the ways that you
can indeed mitigate climate change or
more focus on sort of the general
objectives
I personally believe and so does the
IPCC there are cost-effective approaches
to dealing with climate change today but
there are some real challenges there are
scientific uncertainties there is no
doubt about that but there is the
potential for irreversible damage such
as species loss
there are lags between the emissions and
the effects it is a global problem and
there are and I hate that the word
winners and losers but there are wide
variations in the impacts the question
is what is the optimist stabilization
level how do you get there for an
emissions pathway and what's the right
choice or an appropriate choice of
technologies and policies I think a
major point needs to be taken into
account is the time dimension even if
you were to stabilize today the
atmospheric emissions are co2 you cannot
stabilize the concentrations for many
centuries the lifetime of co2 is over a
hundred years
so just stabilizing emissions today
atmospheric concentrations go up for
centuries even if you could stabilize
the atmospheric concentration of co2 the
temperature legs by a few decades to as
much as maybe half a century
once you stabilize temperature sea level
continues to go up for many centuries
ecosystems could be disturbed and even
if you believe they could be restored it
could take decades or centuries and
species loss is irreversible so from a
scientific perspective the environmental
system has long inertia's significantly
inertia but we also have to recognize it
if we want to deal with climate change
we need to deal it with it in the most
cost-effective way and we have to
realize that capital stock turnover
ranges from years for lightbulbs to
centuries for power plants the key point
here is if you wait for perfect
knowledge and you do not like that
change climate you cannot reverse it not
for decades not for centuries but
potentially millennia this is a very
simple calculation
model would show it you double
atmospheric co2 the blue line over the
next 70 years
you hold co2 absolutely constant that's
what happens to sea level it
monotonically Rises for 600 years here
and I could have run the model out for
two thousand years or five thousand
years this is one of the issues once you
once you force climate to start changing
you cannot reverse it quickly clearly
then governments decide that the time
for action is now I've already said the
residence on co2 is more than a more
than a century the policymakers
recognized that you cannot wait for
perfect knowledge and they recognize the
precautionary principle applies at least
all of them did but the US Senate where
are the co2 emissions going up primarily
in developing countries there is no
question that to date most of the
greenhouse gases have been put in by the
so called annex one or the developed
world over the next century the magnum
growth is primarily in developing
countries but let's remember the per
capita emissions the per capita
emissions of the United States and
Europe relative to most developing
countries is a factor of ten or a
hundred again a moral and ethical issue
the government's indeed including the
United States administration signed the
Kyoto Protocol it calls for a five
percent reduction in greenhouse gas
emissions in the commitment period 2008
to 2012 relative to 1990 they also
recognized something called a
flexibility mechons and that is you
could trade carbon on the open market I
believe this is a superb invention it's
like the sulfur market in America you
can now make carbon a commodity the
interesting thing there is not only
carbon from energy systems that you can
trade but it now gives real value to
carbon in ecological systems it may be
an incredible financing mechanism to
slow down deforestation in the tropics
and so the issues again of climate and
biodiversity can once again be linked it
doesn't sound like a five percent
reduction in 2010 relative to 1990 is
very much
but in a business business-as-usual
scenario our view is that the United
States and Europe would be something
like 24 percent above the 1990 levels
rather than 5% below without the Kyoto
Protocol so in essence the challenge
isn't a five percent reduction it's a 30
percent reduction relative to the
plausible future so it's not trivial but
it's an essential first step to start
start to protect the Earth's climate
system in 2100 this shows what would it
take to stabilize atmospheric levels of
co2 the blue line for example here is
the 550 line double pre-industrial many
NGOs would argue it's that's too high
European Union has put 550 as
effectively its target remind you today
we're at 360 the European uses let's try
and stabilize that to 550 what would
that take in a business-as-usual world
where we don't have a convention in the
year 2100
we'd reject 20 billion tons a year up
from six to a 20 this suggests you would
never have globally more than eight nine
nine and a half billion tons and then it
would rapidly have to decrease to less
than today
so no mean feat to stabilize at five
fifty to remind you the environmental
NGOs believe it should be 450 or even
less
it also means though this cannot be done
by the developed world alone even if you
zeroed out which is of course impossible
emissions in the annex one or the
developed world eventually the
developing countries because of that
projected growth I showed you would have
to take on obligations without going
into the details if we wanted to
stabilize at 450 developing countries
would have to have obligations by 2015
and even stabilizing at 550 they'd have
to have obligations by 2030 this means
it has to be collaboration between the
developed and the developing world with
both financial mechanisms and technology
transfer including education and
knowledge transfer even stabilizing at
550 still means more than a two degrees
centigrade change it doesn't mean
stopping climate change it means
limiting it to two degrees if
at 7:50 which some people have advocated
that means stopping it at three and a
half degrees centigrade
what sort of plausible world would
potentially save us there's actually
done by shell they looked at the
potential governance structures in the
world where the American economic power
triumphed or whether the Asian markets
took over they actually looked at the
sort of population economic growth the
potential of it there new energy systems
coming on board and this is not a
projection as bit as a plausible future
that they're now thinking about British
Petroleum has done something similar
their view was that fossil fuels will
continue to be important over the next
50 years but the new emerging
technologies of wind biomass solar are
going to become more and more important
such by 2050 2060 one may have an energy
market that's only half fossil fuel and
is effectively half half and I just
didn't reminded that wind power is also
extremely important as well which is
indeed true the wind power is actually
there in blue I forgot to mention it yes
I know I've got one more for two more
view for us so the point is how do you
get there in reality it's not technology
in my opinion is actually getting the
economic policies right you need you
need secretary form to get rid of
perverse economic subsidies for energy
for fossil fuels when you do that it
helps to promote energy efficiency it
helps to make a more level playing field
for renewable energies we have to focus
on renewable energy we need to
internalize the environmental pollution
cost of local environmental pollution so
we need economic instruments we need
standards we need regional agreements
but most of all we need more renewable
energy and we need trading systems to
bring the cost of energy down the last
comment I'd like to make is very simply
has this has this ever worked before the
answer is on the ozone issue yes there
was a complete success there was a
wonderful link between advances in
science the international scientific
assessment and policy conversion from
1985 to 1995 we made a series of
discoveries with respect to the ozone
hole mero Molina who won a Nobel Prize
for his pioneering work with sherry
Rowland
who's in the audience here today play
the key role in this but as we
understood the science we interpreted it
through the International assessment so
the whole scientific community and the
policy community listen and there was a
series of decisions such that
effectively now all along live chlorine
and bromine containing compounds are
being phased out
atmospheric chlorine has not only peaked
it's starting to go down
we actually avoided and this is
effectively what we're now seeing it's
peaked and it's going down it avoided a
world where chlorine could have gone up
to 25 parts per million it's now
effectively about three and a half and
starting to go down how did we
accomplished it and what do we need in
climate or biodiversity solid research
from the individual researcher national
research programs its own principal
investigators national international
programs the policy formulation is
absolutely critical of the government's
with the big international conventions
their science bodies the assessment
process is critical if you don't have an
international assessment one country
uses one piece of science another
country uses another piece of science so
the national and international
assessment process which is brings in
the scientists the technologies the
economists and the ethicist which is
absolutely critical it's between the
ethical dimension absolutely critical we
need financial instruments including how
to make the market work and the role of
civil society the general public the
NGOs industry in the media absolutely
critical the bottom line is we need
political will we need better science
there's no question but even more we
need political will and we need to take
an integrated approach if indeed we are
to protect our environment thank you
you